one of the statements that you made in
the talent of the campaign in the
midterms there we go that well if you
know - president that this Caravan was
an invasion as you know I consider it to
be known as presidents caravan was not
an invasion it's a it's a group of
migrants moving up from Central America
towards the border with the u.s. thank
you for Dan why did you why did you
characterize it as such
as I consider an invasion you and I have
a difference of it but do you think that
you demonized immigrants none as
electron now to try want them I want
them to come into the country but they
have to come in Legally you know they
have to come and Jim through a process I
want it to be a process and I want
people to come in and we need the people
your campaign your wait you know why we
need the people - because we have
hundreds of companies moving in we need
the people your campaign had an ad
showing migrants climbing over walls and
so it for it but they weren't act
they're not gonna be doing they weren't
actors well no it's just do you think
they were actors they wanted actives
they didn't come from Hollywood these
were these were people this was an
actual you know it happened a few days
ago and there are hundreds of miles away
though there are hundreds and hundreds
of more no way that that's not an
evasion honestly I think you should let
me run the country you run CNN or and if
you did it well your ratings let me ask
mr. president but are you worried that's
enough
that's one of the other folks that said
enough pardon me ma'am
mr. president that's enough this
president I had one of these I may ask
you on on the Russian investigation are
you concerned that that you may have not
concerned about anything with you main
investigation because it's a hoax are
you that's enough put down the mic mr.
president are you worried about
indictments coming down in this
investigation
mr. president I'll tell you what CNN
should be ashamed of itself having you
working for them you are a rude terrible
person you shouldn't be working for CNN
go ahead I think that's on you're very
rude person the way you treat Sarah
Huckabee is horrible and the way you
treat other people are horrible you
shouldn't treat people that way go ahead
go ahead Peter go in Jim's defense I've
traveled with him and watched him he's a
diligent reporter big fan of yours
either so I understand to be honest
right so let me ask you a question if I
can you repeatedly heart you are the
best
mr. president you repeatedly over the
course of the gist sit down please
well when you when you report fake news
no when you report fake news which CNN
does a lot you are the enemy of the
people go ahead mr. president over the
course over the course of the last
several days of the campaign sir sir at
the end of the campaign you repeatedly
said that Americans need to fear
Democrats you said Democrats would
unleash a wave of violent crime that
endangers families everywhere why are
you crying why are you pitting Americans
against one another Cena what are you
trying to be him no let me just tell you
very simple because they're very weak on
crime be questioned to be clear that the
quiet very much why are you sit down but
the questions but you didn't answer my
question just very simply the question
is why are you pitting Americans against
one another sir I'm not that how you
view how I'm citizens of this country
what we want a lot of elections last
night we did very well last night
in many ways I think I think it's going
to have a very positive impact i watch
the NBC this morning they didn't report
it exactly correctly but that's you know
very very that's the fact with NBC
nothing I can do about that but I want
this country to have protection we want
security in our country I want you if
it's on guys to president
if it's unfair to the country and it's
costing millions of dollars why don't
you just give him the mic please I've
answered the question go ahead take the
peg line
well I'll give you voters I will give
you voter suppression you just have to
sit down please sit down I didn't call
you I didn't call you I didn't call you
I'll give you a voter suppression take a
look at the CNN polls how inaccurate
they were
that's called voter suppression go ahead
please Thank You mr. president
I'm not I'm not responding I'm
responding to excuse me I'm not
responding to you I'm talking to this
gentleman will you please sit down
which excuse me excuse me would you
please sit down please go ahead Thank
You mr. president
now that the now that the House of
Representative media it's so said you
asked me but no you rudely interrupted
him you rudely interrupted him go ahead
Thank You mr. president